[Music]
and lyre lyre news I still can't do it
submitted by Garten Bo cart there's like
Gio and Bart but they switch the first
lip part it's not like Bo no Gardenview
jim carrey
alrighty then I loved gleams his late
girlfriend lied about her STD status in
an effort to extort him say I really
hope that's true cuz I love to carry
because every every like celebrity
nowadays has so much dirt coming out
about them my childhood is being [ __ ]
destroyed it started with coffee and
then [ __ ] raping like 90 people ok
rate 90 people I do that too if I was
untouchable trust you I'm just joking
guys
I like the chase no no I like it when I
get chased how about that and if
anything because I'm in the position of
power
I like the reverse gangbang I want to be
the guy that's like being helplessly
gangbang if I have a girlfriend now so
those dreams are over it's not even a
dream ok had an argument but I just know
that sometimes I get myself in trouble
because I don't explain things
thoroughly so I I must do so because the
audience hey what if it's their first
time and they don't know who I am and
they see this video and they go this
guy's not right you know you should
start doing that little flute thing that
you blew horribly yeah but what you
should do is this means I don't have to
say another [ __ ] word whatever I said
I'm not as serious as you think I am
[ __ ] off
[Laughter]
and that tells you everything
yeah it means I didn't mean it exactly I
wish I could get away with the media
sucking in debt just for the record
there's a lot of guys out there that
have rape fantasies because that porn
category exists but that's not one of my
things I like to say something
outlandish and then you play the [ __ ]
flu you could say like I hate Jews yeah
because you're like I hate pedophiles
contradicting flu I pet turtle dick that
are contradictory fluid that's what I
did your old welcome all right so do you
guys remember when we talked about Jim
Carrey and his girlfriend who committed
suicide back in 2010 he gave her a STD
and that was one of the factors that
made her go bleep in my mind Jim Carrey
is still with jenni Gallardo wow that
was like she's with the Backstreet Boy
Oh
oh no I just named the only no I can't
remember his name
no isn't Marky Mark Mark Wahlberg's
brother something Wahlberg there marry
Donnie Wahlberg the Donnie Wahlberg he's
a bastard we'll have a cute orange new
kid
[Laughter]
that's so contradictory funny the
[ __ ] what a white guy here this
racially profile we all look the same
we're boring looking skin
[Laughter]
wait a minute
what STD that's the only I can think
about is what Estes yeah we're talking
about like chlamydia that could get rid
of it he gave me chlamydia I'm gonna
kill myself that's not you know somebody
you know so HPV everyone gets a little
committee of the time yeah so she
commits suicide back in 2015 she took a
lot of prescription pills and that's how
she died when the prescription pills
were under an alias for Jim Carrey so
they're saying that Jim Carrey should be
responsible for her suicide because they
were his pills and she was also saying
that she became very suicidal because he
gave her STDs so she claims but now who
is he supposed to [ __ ] Lauren's
medicine cabinet what do you do give her
AIDS no it was her big one herpes - and
there's levels of herpes I think it was
syphilis I think Steve syphilis that's
no no no gonorrhea syphilis is actually
more its deadliest [ __ ] is it nowadays
it's crazy with 40 cases hey Tobin had
syphilis certain Hitler very good good
but now Jim Carrey's legal team is
saying that she fabricated medical
documents that says so pretty much she
ended up teaming up with a friend of
hers she got her friends clean medical
records changed the dates and all the
information on it
and to say that it was her clean records
when in reality this is all according
the Jim Carrey's legal team she already
had a CDs when she started dating him so
she had given him the herpes of the ones
and twos he his legal team is saying
like she already had STDs she lied on
these records and she was trying to
extort him her and her a torn her
attorney we're trying to extort him back
in 2013 but he said like he are he's
been conned before and doesn't that seem
like a weird way to go about it
extorting someone or like you know
trying to get someone in trouble like
she's saying that she changed her bill
of health
so Jim Carrey's legal team is saying
that she's records to say that she was
clean before that's just a weird thing
that's just like that's a professional
con artists and I'm trying to figure out
to like man grow you got you got herps
one two syphilis and gonorrhea oh okay
what does Jim Carrey have I know that's
what I can't think even though how many
dollars I could care a lot of things
yeah does Jim Carrey have things hasn't
been addressed I don't know because you
know every time I think of a major actor
on the big silver screen I think you got
AIDS Michael was a part of my childhood
in a different show and that show was
like clean it's very difficult all more
Simpson had AIDS I'd be like oh [ __ ] I
didn't expect that can you match that
one to everyone now all more time let's
try it it's a weird one it's like you
know you just can't you don't go around
saying Oh Jim Carrey has this and you
know you want to just get to the facts
you want to get to the you know it needs
to go to court and they need to figure
it out
don't give a [ __ ] about the facts you
want the drama there's so much drama in
that Twitter by the way it's like it
just it just has become drama central
well it's it's like The Enquirer
yeah it's just headlines it's like
someone so did this someone so did that
everyday what can we get to just you
know it's a crack that's a big it gets
to her it's like oh my god isn't doesn't
anything good happen anymore is there
any good things that's why you have to
come on just came news itself
incriminate yourself you say [ __ ] about
yourself before anybody else can yeah
hey that's why people love me these are
like mini loads in here they put too
many in there it's kind of like if you
already do the deed then nothing will
shock the public right so like if let's
say I don't know say out the right stay
off the rape let's say let's say adios
born is like oh you know guess what he
did coke when he was a rock star is
anyone gonna go oh my god the pillar of
the communities just [ __ ] doing coke
not it's it's Ozzy right so you just you
gotta put yourself out there honestly as
a hundred percent as you can and then
people just see a scoundrel ya know
there's nothing there's nothing to hide
everybody fabricates like this this this
angelic form of who they are but then I
think like when you get into edit to
even like YouTube right you'll see who
these people are when you get to meet
them and they're all pieces of [ __ ] you
know the only difference is with us
we're open about ours and they like to
hide their [ __ ] and so when their [ __ ]
blows up
people are so flabbergasted by you know
oh holy crap this is who that actually I
like bit like Disney kind of people yeah
super wholesome but then they love gang
bangs on a Friday night yeah Friday
night gang bangs well it's hard because
everybody wants their perception out
there to be like squeaky clean and I
don't do this and I believe in this and
the the second you say something anybody
disagrees with especially if it's a
majority yeah you know you are
lambasted you are just [ __ ] you
[ __ ] racist
you're a [ __ ] not you're just [ __ ]
it's it's like and I'm pretty [ __ ]
liberal but now it's almost like there's
two [ __ ] liberal likes it gets to a
point where I feel like I can't honestly
can't say anything
I cannot even if I want to say something
I stopped writing because I'm like
they're gonna think I'm something yeah
it's good so we're trying to get
involved I'm just gonna just have a
donate to charities and be a good person
and help out and try to be have a good
soul it'd be good to my family I'm not
gonna involve myself on Twitter
[Laughter]
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it I know you did
but guess what you can also follow us on
our personal social media accounts with
the links in the description box below
so both follow all of us now to watch
more videos check out there
[Music]